they spent 13 months even at this
because their lack of traditional ed
them to do serious injury you could not
win against the New York Times because
New York Times so giant media
they also long is very easy to open the
business compared to other business over
the last 28 years it grew a lot Donald
Yoo is the chairman of the
korean-american nail salon Association
which was founded in 1987 at a time when
the nail business was just beginning to
emerge out of beauty parlors as its own
industry there are still mom and pop
shops they work hard they work long
hours they save money to live better
nail salons also provide vital
employment opportunities to thousands of
recent immigrants many of whom live here
in Flushing Queens and that's where the
controversy begins in May of 2015 the
New York Times published a blockbuster
story arguing that those basement prices
for mani-pedis are in the backs of
immigrant workers earning wages as low
as $10 per day immediately after the
story appeared Governor Andrew Cuomo
reacted today we're starting a
multi-agency effort to help women who
work in nail salons they are extorted
and they are victimized many of them
don't even get paid the minimum wage
actually that's not true
nail salon workers are skilled employees
whose labor is in high demand and they
have a good deal of bargaining power the
New York Times story that inspired
Cuomo's crackdown broadly
mischaracterized the nail salon industry
and some of the men and women the
reporter spoke with say she misquoted
them or misrepresented their businesses
the author and editors of the New York
Times story declined reasons interview
requests I read the story and talked to
my wife about it we both felt that the
story was just so far from the the world
that we've experienced over the last 12
years that it was wrong Richard
Bernstein spent 24 years of the New York
Times serving as a bureau chief in
Berlin in Paris a book critic culture
reporter and UN correspondent before
leaving the paper in 2006 Bernstein made
the difficult decision to publicly
criticize his old employers
nail salon coverage with an article
published in the online edition of the
New York Review of Books in July his
knowledge of the industry is based on
the first-hand experience of his wife
Zhang Mei Lee who is co-owned two nail
salons in Manhattan for the past twelve
years
I can't crawl into the heads of the
writer of the story and her editors I
can only assume that they had the best
of intentions and the best of motives
they early on felt that they had
discovered a story of massive injustice
and consciously or unconsciously they
sifted out anything that didn't fit with
that narrative the main claim of the
time story is that nail salon workers
are paid shockingly low wages one of the
primary pieces of evidence offered to
support that claim newspaper ads
Bernstein pointed out that The Times
reporter misrepresented what the
classified ads say about the industry
the story claimed that the Asian
language papers are rife with classified
ads for manicurists listing salaries so
low do you think at first if they were
typos Bernstein found that the Asian
language newspapers are actually filled
with ABS offering day wages of more like
eighty a hundred dollars and
occasionally much more and these figures
don't include tips or Commission's which
can sometimes equal or exceed base pay
after Bernstein's article appeared the
times editor's posted three examples to
support their claim two ads they said
offered to pay just 40 dollars per day
and one ad offered to pay forty to 90
dollars per day but is this really what
the ads say the images of the paper
provided were too blurry to read but a
look back at the originals reveals that
two were posted by the same person
according to the salon owner who took
out those ads they don't offer a day
wage of forty dollars they say that a
mani-pedi costs forty dollars and the
text of the ads backs him up he said in
a phone interview that the idea was to
indicate to prospective candidates that
he runs an expensive shot which means
they can earn big tips
the third ad offers a range of 40 to 90
dollars because according to the salon
owner the forty dollars was for
part-time employee
and then it goes on to cite a particular
ad offering jobs for $10 a day what the
times didn't mention is that the ad it
was referring to actually offers to a
skilled manicurist $75 per day under
that it says that trainees can make $10
but the times defended its failure to
mention that the ads specified that the
$10 was for trainees writing that the
paper had confirmed that these were
essentially beginning workers doing the
same jobs as others in the salon but
that's not true according to the man who
posted the $10 and commented enemy this
is a consolation see the tissue density
on Toyota young to more soul
so yarn to Tempe just angle TG but the
don't vote Union long is the former
co-owner and manager of New York City
nail spa I Manhattan's Upper West Side
okay I'm up on curtana Eureka is a hot
seller Tahoe bouquet kit hey go Bhutan
so they're going to full-color fool not
a credible computer long says the reason
he attempted to train his own workers is
that there's a shortage of qualified
manicurist in the nail salon industry so
finding people is a constant struggle
and that's precisely why the classifieds
are jammed with one ads offering
competitive wages the classified ads
actually disprove the thesis of the
times after reading Bernstein's critique
and reasons investigation New York Times
public editor Margaret Sullivan weighed
in writing that the paper went too far
in generalizing about an entire industry
and that its findings and the language
used to express them should have been
dialed back in some instances
substantially
I knew time was distorted fast so much
they spent 13 month to get all affair to
distort didn't demonize dis he does it
about five months after the New York
Times series first appeared nail salon
owners staged a series of protests to
complain about the papers inaccurate
reporting so I think the first article
had May 11
Ron Kim is a New York State Assemblyman
from Flushing in Aryan Queens where many
nail salon workers live my advice to the
community at that time was let's just
calm down we will be poor the news cycle
and people focus on the next issue and
that wasn't the case it kept snowballing
the new state task force that formed in
response to the times as coverage
started conducting surprise inspections
of nail salons and issuing large fines
these inspections have exposed that many
shops don't keep detailed records and
they often pay their workers much of
their salaries off the books this
violates New York State swaging our
regulations but it doesn't show that
workers are being cheated of decent pay
workers themselves that prefer to be
paid in cash but how do you actually
prove that right later on if they get
audited that's not just they also know
is that kind of practices as in many
other sectors the labor inspections have
also had the unintended consequence of
closing off opportunities for immigrant
workers if the worker is not documented
they now feel comfortable hiring them
and using them in the store
second when you come up you said they
don't have a what you saw secrete number
a tax ID number that we now allow the
hide then we got so confused no over the
summer the pressure on shop owners
intensified when Governor Cuomo issued
an emergency order requiring every nail
salon to purchase what's called a wage
bond it's essentially a form of
insurance that if the government
determines that nail salon workers are
owed back pay they have to collect you
can see you do you wanna control achieve
headache again shion-san Medusa Medusa
Medusa Medusa hydro lava Salon de Mayo
what we go well mayor twiddle what you
that the hoop email Twitter so far only
the Chinese nail salon owners have been
protesting the Korean Association was
advised early on not to go up against
the times directly what people told us
was you could not win against on your
time because New York Times so so
cherien
so we are trying to find other ways to
fight the Korean Association along with
another industry group filed a lawsuit
in New York State Supreme Court to stop
the governor's wage bond requirement
you know just asking the nurse alone to
purchase the wage bond I feel that the
discriminating creations I'd love the
New York Times by the way I read it
every day and I worked there for 20 40
years I think in this instance their
lack of judicious nough slid them to do
serious injury Assemblyman Kim is one of
the only elected officials fighting back
against more government regulation from
nail salons and for him the issue is
personal Kim comes from a
first-generation Korean family his aunts
first job in the country was as a
factory worker then she became a
manicurist and ultimately opened her own
chain of successful nail shops I want to
make sure that
people like my odds right now also has
an equal chance to succeed
you